what has been like the day-to-day change
that you've seen since your star has
really been rising probably more
pictures of my daughter standing in
front of posters you know that's kind of
fun now it's the other part of the
business you know they don't talk about
in drama school like you got to promote
the film I mean there's a bit more you
know Mr majors and I kind of I kind of
shut that down immediately Jay is fine
bro you know James preferred you know
does your baby girl get it I don't know
I think she's just uh she's just happy
yeah I mean like that and that's all I
can hope for she knows I I'm an actor
I've actually been an actor her entire
life we don't live in hotels anymore you
know she knows that you're gonna make me
cry